[Music]  this could use a brand new coat  that's not allowed I'd warn you don't  that guy is crapping on the ground it  happens wait how's that even allowed  cause you're living in a cloud a world a  cool to pull your pants on down  Ward there's only one you can paint  Brown World you'll never guess which one  in clown world the cost of rent is  getting here  we should build our new neighborhood  here  Zoning for bids new housing builds we're  actually just gonna throw up some tents  and you know do some heroin well that's  acceptable and clown  they can't let children walk downtown a  world they're playing hopscotch look  around the world they're avoiding  needles oh it's okay and clown world he  saved that disabled lady  wrist is like to save two rabies  Valor we're in debt wait have you had  your booster yet well I've had covet and  I had a napper skin for a new job and  clown the world a risk your life so they  don't  [Music]  work  fired is dangerous  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]